Ніж, черпак і кріп. Це емблема "Кухарської сотні столиці".
І якщо українські військові в окопах і бліндажах на Донбасі бачать її на сухпайку,
о точно знають, що це буде запашний, як у матусі, борщ "Столичний".
Наша фішка - зерна кропу перемелені.
Він тоді ароматніше стає. Всі ефірні масла переходять в сіль.
На п’ятому році війни на Донбасі волонтерська група "Кухарська сотня столиці"
продовжує виробляти сухпайки для військових.
48-річна киянка Світлана Козіна - її засновниця.
І чи не єдина, хто може виконати ось цю роботу - змішувати спеції.
В нас такі термоядерні …
…Перець та часник. Особливо, коли  часник та цибулю сушити в квартирі…
Це бомба.
Ніяких паразитів не буде, і ще і сусіди порозбігаються
Десятки кілограмів висушеної капусти, моркви, буряків, м’яса.
В 2014-му сотні українських жінок,
реагуючи на повідомлення про повну відсутність поставок харчування в українські підрозділи,
повитягували свої сушильні камери і відкрили на своїх кухнях
справжнісінький фронт опору.
В листопаді 2014-го Світлана вирішила
об’єднати зусилля усіх київських "сушарок " в одну групу - "Кухарська сотня столиці".
У перший місяць її існування жінки виготовили
500 пакетів сухого борщу, в другий - більше тисячі.
А в 2015-му взагалі щомісяця робили не менше півтори тисячі пакетів.
У "Кухарській сотні " за п'ять років війни
встигли взяти участь кілька десятків жінок.
Удень вони ходять на роботу, а ввечері чи інколи навіть уночі
фасують і пакують сухпайки.
На п'ятому році нам вже трохи важко.
Якщо поки потребують
хлопці … мають бути нагодовані.
Але все одно це з задоволенням.  Поки ти сунешся сюди, ти вже ніякий.
Ти вже їдеш такий, щоб тебе так поклали і ти вже ліг спати.
А ти розумієш, що ти зараз прийдеш, душ прийняв,
смачну вечерю поїв, і все спокійно.
А там ой-йой-йой.
А там постріли, а там смерть і дуже-дуже важко.
Тому бігом, зібрав свої думки. Клац! І прийшов - і але-оп!
Насправді, зізнаються жінки, їм останнім часом геть не весело.
Ще кілька місяців тому вони думали, що працюють останні дні.
Адже замовлень з фронту поменшало,
оскільки постачання продуктів для армії помітно покращилося.
До того ж, волонтери при Міноборони
розробили і розпочали реформу харчування ЗСУ за натівськими стандартами.
Мета реформи - звести до  мінімуму корупційні ризики при держзакупівлях продуктів
для армії і збільшити асортимент цих продуктів.
Усі роки війни бійців годували ще за радянською системою -
в харчуванні було 30 видів продуктів.
Планувалося, що в цьому і наступному році в армії
"військовий продуктовий кошик " мав би мати 400 різних продуктів.
І на цьому тлі, каже Світлана, по всій країні
почали припиняти свою діяльність кухарські сотні на кшталт київської.
Але вже влітку стало зрозуміло, що зупинятися ще не час.
Натівські стандарти харчування в армії України зупинив суд.
Один з постачальників продуктів в ЗСУ не погодився з тим,
що система закупівель у межах харчової реформи буде змінюватися,
і наразі оскаржує це в судовому порядку.
Йдуть суди з приводу того, щоб зупинити
стандарти харчування по натівській системі.
А якщо йде суд, то система припиняє впроваджуватися.
І вони досі йдуть,
а у хлопців вже все стає погано з харчуванням.
Вони ж чекати не будуть, бо вони ж їсти хочуть.
Тому ми знов почали збиратися більше, частіше
і робити знов нашу продукцію.
Натівська система харчування в армії  - це коли ось такі  сухпайки -
борщі та супи, каші в вакуумній упаковці  - меншого розміру,
вироблені в промислових умовах, щоб продукт потребував лише розігріву,
щоб зберігався кілька років. Розробляти армійську харчову реформу
волонтери Міноборони почали в 2015-му,
але офіційний наказ про впровадження реформи
з’явився лише навесні цього року.
Дуже повільні кроки назустріч реформам відверто дратують волонтерку Оксану.
На мою особисту думку, міністерство оборони в нас було на канікулах всі ці роки.
Не знаю, де воно ходило, що воно робило,
наше диво-міністерство. Але те, що зробили волонтери для нашої армії,
це дійсно героїчно, тому що кожен ніс останнє.
Всі сушили, давали гроші, пакували,
плели сітки. Дуже багато чого робив народ.
А що робило Міноборони, не можу сказати.
У суворих умовах війни бійцям, особливо в холоднечу,
що вже наближається, бракуватиме вітамінних чаїв.
Волонтерка Тетяна це точно знає, бо перші три роки війни об’їхала багато підрозділів.
Дивлячись на результати харчової реформи, вона починає сумніватися,
чи не замало влітку насушила листя вишні та липи.
Тетяна вважає, що слід бути готовим до гіршого.
Адже через суди може призупинитися не лише впровадження натівських стандартів ,
а й закупівля продуктів на наступний рік в цілому.
Ми їх контролюємо, так, йдуть суди,
скасовують, але ми слідкуємо.
І  ми не дамо такої можливості, щоб наші хлопці там залишилися голодні.
"Кухарська сотня" самотужки вже не сушить овочі.
Цей бізнес з виготовлення сухпайків за останні роки дуже розвинувся в Україні,
і волонтерки закуповують інгредієнти у підприємців.
Кажуть, їм дають неабияку знижку.
Гроші волонтеркам, як і раніше, надсилають небайдужі.
Серед них, зокрема, і люди  з окупованих територій,
які всі роки війни щомісяця роблять внески.
Водночас бажаючих допомогти армії, кажуть жінки,
поменшало - помітно, що люди втомилися від війни.
Серед благодійників багато родичів тих, хто відправився на фронт.
Як оцей чоловік. Такий же мішок він відправив і сину на Донбас.
Це подарунок. Літом посушили, і бачите, які красиві.
З цього мішка і з ось цих насушених лимонів і сухофруктів
можна наробити багато порцій так званого "набору розвідника".
На випадок, коли під обстрілами неможливо готувати собі їжу.
14 жовтня відзначають День захисника України.
Офіційна назва свята на разі не вказує на те, що це ще і день захисниць.
Волонтерки кухарської сотні скромно кажуть,
що прямо таки захисницями себе не вважають,
скоріше - "надійним прикриттям з тилу".
За три години роботи вони встигли виконати замовлення одного з батальйонів,
який нещодавно зайшов на позиції.
Завершують роботу традиційним побажанням:
"Від усіх жінок України - смачного!"
А вже за два дні волонтерки зустрінуться знову -
виконувати наступне  замовлення з фронту.